[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale avec tv 78
très heureux de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau 7,8 journal nous sommes le lundi
28 janvier tout de suite les titres de
cette édition c'est la journée
européenne de protection des données
celles ci sont aujourd'hui traités par
tous au travail lors d'achats de biens
ou de services ou tout simplement lors
de recherches sur internet un enjeu de
cyber sécurité pour les particuliers
mais aussi pour les entreprises
reportages et invités à suivre
l'acteur 11 des gilets jaunes samedi
près de 100 personnes ont répondu
présent pour une mobilisation organisée
dans les yvelines les participants ont
effectué une marche citoyenne et
solidaire entre poissy et
saint-germain-en-laye nous étions dans
le cortège enfin comme chaque fin de
mois le dossier de la rédaction à cette
fin janvier nous nous sommes intéressés
à l'aide aux plus démunis dans les
yvelines quelles associations agissent
quelles actions sont déployés sur le
territoire ce soir
focus sur les bénévoles du resto du
coeur à suivre également les résultats
sport du week-end est une initiative
insolite trouver un emploi grâce à un
match de football nous en parlons tout à
l'heure avec notre invité saulnier
arrighi de lagence hacktivity
aujourd'hui donc journée européenne de
la protection des données
la première depuis l'application du rgp
décès le règlement européen sur le sujet
avant d'en parler avec mes invités ce
reportage maintenant varaldo s'est rendu
ce matin dans un atelier d'initiation et
de sensibilisation aux nouvelles
technologies pour les seniors c'était à
voisins le bretonneux regarder la
journée mondiale de protection des
données est l'occasion de sensibiliser
les personnes danger menace de la
cybercriminalité et les seniors sont des
cibles potentielles pour faciliter
l'accès aux nouvelles technologies et
développer les usages du web
plusieurs modules étaient proposés à
l'espace net public de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est apprendre à
bien différencier tous les
et tout ce qu'on peut nous proposer en
termes de serveurs donc de cloud de bien
protéger ses données au niveau même de
son ordinateur smartphone tablette
numérique
on a vu par exemple mais jamais laisser
un disque dur lorsqu'on géant l'ange est
un ordinateur la déchetterie les données
ont changé elles vont aujourd'hui bien
au-delà de nos simples coordonnées dans
un annuaire téléphonique à l'ère du
numérique elle les données personnelles
en globe nos contacts nos lectures nos
photos que les seniors apprennent à
gérer avec le cloud au début que j'étais
à la retraite j'ai suivi le sensation
sur la photo je comment se servir d'un
ordinateur également on a toujours des
doutes quand on doit se servir d'un
réalisateur donc on a toujours peur de
mal faire mais années qui arrivent nous
nous oblige à utiliser un ordinateur
internet
il faut pas que les personnes plus 60
ans soit laissé sur le bord du chemin
côté du chemin parce qu'une sauront pas
utilisent ou vous recevoir des news que
ce soit d or acc que ça soit des du
phishing et les personnes âgées sont des
victimes potentielles
d'autres ateliers sont proposés jusqu'au
14 février plus de 2,5 milliards
d'octets de données sont créés chaque
jour et pour par les cyber sécurité plus
particulièrement de la protection des
données en sept journées européennes
deux invités autour de cette table
christophe boissonnade bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes premier adjoint de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux en charge
notamment de la ville numérique
précisant que vous êtes également
délégué à la protection des données pour
une fédération de mutuelle avec vous sur
ce plateau claudio 6 rebonds soir vous
êtes le président d'al mitis est une
entreprise spécialisée dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité vous êtes basé à
saint quentin en yvelines et vous
travaillé notamment avec des grands
comptes mais aussi des tpe et pme petit
tour de table messieurs pour commencer
quels sont les enjeux aujourd'hui autour
de la cybersécurité est ce qu'ils sont
grands et est ce que c'est pour ça à
voisins que vous organisez ce genre
d'atelier comme l'a très bien dit
yannick bigaud qui s'occupe de l'espace
public numérique et de ces formations là
il n'y a ni que je salue parce qu'il
part à la retraite il a fait un travail
remarquable sur la formation des gens ce
qui est important c'est déjà de laisser
personne sur le bord de la route et de
sensibiliser tout le monde ça c'est une
première chose parce que la société
numérique elle a tendance à être
exclusive
et puis pour les gens qui sont pas nés
avec ces outils là c'est vraiment pas
évident de rentrer dans ce monde là la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est une
question de cohérence
aujourd'hui nous avons une police
municipale pour protéger les biens et
les personnes qui donnent des bons
conseils comme laissez pas les clefs sur
la porte quand vous partez en vacances
et pour tout ce qui est immatériel on
ferait pas attention à nos données donc
le rôle aussi de ces ateliers c'est de
former les gens pour qu'ils soient
vraiment alertés et vigilant sur tous
ces outils un enjeu d'autant plus
important claudio sirbu que depuis 2016
a été votée alors ça c'est la donne a
changé
le rg pdc la réglementation sur la
protection des données c'est un
règlement européen et s'il vraie
révolution en matière de protection des
données ce texte complètement s'éteint
c'est un vrai changement c'est le
passage de de la donnée personnelle qui
est vécu comme produit de consommation
pour des grosses multinationales au
passage de la donnée personnelle qui
protège la vie privée du citoyen donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui est arrivé alors en
europe
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
n'existe pas à ma connaissance dans
d'autres pays en deux zones
géographiques on précise juste que ce
rgpp est appliquée depuis le printemps
dernier printemps 2010 8 sur le
territoire de l'union européenne est par
exemple un exemple concret google qui a
été qui a été sanctionné par la cnil
grâce au 1er gp des 30 millions 50
millions d'euros pardon d'amande ça veut
dire que ce rg et efficace en tout
cas il est efficace oui et puis
effectivement il cible particulièrement
les grosses plates-formes
multinationales comme le disait monsieur
qui dit pineau données de façon
consciente ou inconsciente parce qu'on a
tous tendance à mettre un peu tout et
n'importe quoi sur les réseaux sociaux
mais il ya aussi tout un tas de
technologies qui sont fait à notre insu
puis on a tous un petit ordinateur dans
nos poches qui capte ces données qui
valorise énormément ces sociétés là mais
on n'a pas toujours conscience d'eux
de toutes les données qui fuitent
directement des appareils de plus en
plus connectés la protection des données
c'est vraiment le thème but en fait on
se balade au quotidien avec avec des
vrais mouchard dans notre poche
quel que soit le smartphone donc c'est
vrai que les données alors aussi il ya
les données comportementales qui fuite
qui peuvent fuite est assez vite sur sur
les réseaux donc c'est vrai que cette
réglementation va elle résout pas tout
puisque la preuve donc mais elle devient
un peu plus elle va sanctionner de plus
en plus et contraignant pour les pour
ceux qui se met en dehors du droit
chemin il ya trois volets ce voulez sur
la protection des données
vous avez le volet technologique et la
cybersécurité est le volet juridique que
vient renforcer le rgp des mets qui
était déjà la loi informatique et
libertés et puis le volet humain et on
s'aperçoit que si on augmente la
protection technologique et la
protection juridique le maillon faible
c'est toujours le facteur humain donc
les gens vont essayer on peut prendre un
cas très concrets vous travaillez par
exemple chez une grande société de saint
quentin en yvelines soit dans le
bâtiment soit peu importe dans
l'aéronautique
vous cliquez sur un mail que vous envoie
votre maman parce que algarve au regard
de vos enfants elle vous envoie une
photo vous cliquez sur la photo pendant
ce temps là vous avez un filtre permis
un petit logiciel d'infiltrer le réseau
et donc ça dépend de la commande après
c'est au niveau de la cyber malveillance
mais ça peut être je pique gg face
toutes les données de la société
il ya plusieurs types de menaces ou
alors je
je me positionne sur le réseau et
j'écoute tout ce qui se passe dessus et
là ça peut être de la perte de contrats
au bout de plusieurs mois vous apercevez
que vous n'avez plus aucun contrat
l'international
voilà ça peut être ça peut être des
choses comme ça avec des conséquences
très très concrète c'est de la perte
d'emploi sont des pertes de contrats
économiques donc pour pour un territoire
pour une ville pour un pays
le mels un vrai point faible le mail
aujourd'hui oui parce qu'on va on va
exploiter vos faiblesses en fait en tant
que personne pour déjouer toutes les
touts les remparts technologiques qui
ont été mis en place
d'après la dernière étude ipsos claudio
cyr vous seuls 19% des pme ont prévue en
2019 des investissements concrets pour
garantir leur cv de cybersécurité vous
qui travaillez avec ces tpe et pme
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'elles ont elles ont pris totalement
ce tournant en termes de cyber sécurité
la protection des données non je n'ai
pas cette impression enfin au quotidien
le l'équipement des en termes
d'équipement dpme ça reste assez assez
faible quand je m'adresse à des chefs
d'entreprise de pme tpe
j'ai une anecdote typiquement là dessus
il ya cinq ans j'avais un client qui
était une tpe et qui me parlait pas trop
de sécurité à chaque fois c'était pour
les autres et puis un jour il s'est fait
avec un mail il s'est fait infiltrer les
données de l'entreprise ont été chiffrés
donc plus plus il était plus en capacité
d'accéder aux données et donc là tout à
coup alors je peux vous le dire que
cette ce client là il est trés
maintenant très à cheval sur la sécurité
mais ce que je remarque qu'en fait c'est
que les tpe pme elles vont plutôt avoir
tendance à prioriser sur l'opérationnel
courants et les idées les tout ce qui
est sujet de sécurité c'est c'est quand
ça arrive malheureusement souvent et
christophe boisseau de parler des
menaces via mail quelles sont les
menaces
aujourd'hui qui existent pour pour ces
entreprises c'est vrai que le mail est
un est un vecteur le plus le plus
répandu puisque aujourd'hui
plus 90 pour 19% des échanges que nous
avons avec l'extérieur c'est via le mail
après il y à d'autres menaces notamment
je pense aux tpe pme qui ont des sites
internet ou qui ont des des applications
internet il ya d'autres menaces qui sont
liées à tout simplement au déni de
service donc ça c'est une autre
c'est une autre menace un autre type
d'attaqué c'est à dire qu'on va
submerger le système avec avec des
requêtes pour le mettre hors service
ces dernières sessions ce qu'on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien très rapidement
les solutions qui existent pour se
protéger pour les particuliers par
exemple pour les particuliers déjà c'est
de bon sens c'est aussi l'éducation
déjà la première chose je dirais les
mots de passe on arrête de mettre la
date de naissance des enfants ou le
prénom du chien ça marche pas bien on
met on met des mots compliqués avec des
majuscules et minuscules des chiffres et
puis des signes ça déjà vous allez
vous allez résoudre 80% des problèmes
avec ça les particuliers côté
entreprises qu'il faut forcément faire
appel à des types d'entreprises comme la
vôtre à le métis pour se protéger on
peut aussi avoir des réflexes pour se
protéger non je dirais que c'est oui oui
non mais je suis pas en train de vendre
nos prestations ce que je dis c'est je
rejoins comme pour les particuliers il
ya un certain nombre de bonnes pratiques
qui sont notamment édité par l'ansi
sinon il ya déjà des bons sites là
dessus c'est gratuit il faut les
appliquer c'est que les gens les
appliquent pas trop par exemple stocker
des mots de passe sur un sur un réseau
sur un fichier excel bas il faut éviter
dans une entreprise même si c'est une
toute petite entreprise voilà il ya déjà
des choses de bon sens qu'il faut mettre
en place et sans forcément attendre qui
est des spécialistes qui vous ont dit
non a compris de grands enjeux autour de
ce thème merci à vous deux christophe
gosden première maire adjoint à voisins
le bretonneux et merci claudio sirbe au
président de la société al métis qui est
basé à guyancourt politique en bref sauf
dernière surprise il devrait être la
tête de liste les républicains pour les
européennes françois xavier bellamy est
plus que jamais pressenti pour conduire
la candidature du parti aux européennes
le 26 mai prochain le président du parti
laurent wauquiez va proposer le nom du
maire adjoint de versailles et demain
mardi lors d'une commission nationale
d'investitures selon plusieurs sources
un choix qui ne ferait pas l'unanimité
en interne en raison des prises de
position du philosophe contre lille et g
françois-xavier bellamy devrait être
suivi sur la liste en deuxième et
troisième position de la conseillère
régionale
agnès séverin et de l'eurodéputé arnaud
danjean
le grand débat national est lancé depuis
le 15 janvier mais déjà plusieurs
réunions sont établis dans les yvelines
vendredi le grand débat investissait par
exemple sartrouville avec un invité
surprise
edouard philippe les 300 participants
ont pu échanger directement avec le
premier ministre dans un climat bon
enfant plusieurs sujets ont été évoqués
avec le chef du gouvernement accompagné
de la députée des yvelines
yaël brawn peavey interrogé par nicolas
landry les thèmes qui ont été abordés
c'est beaucoup
deux thèmes autour de la justice fiscale
à quoi ça sert comment mieux répartir
l'impôt et c'est pour le rendre plus
juste plus équitable
on a beaucoup entendu parler de service
public on a entendu parler de république
d'amour de la france de personnes qui
disait qu'elle était reconnaissante pour
les soins de santé pour l'école
l'éducation la formation qu'ils avaient
reçu beaucoup de défiance vis-à-vis des
élus donc à vrai lien à retisser et des
citoyens qui étaient très respectueux du
débat aussi on a vu qu'il s'écoutent est
qu'il ne ne s'interrompent est pas et
qu'ils étaient respectueux de cela mais
je pense que ça aussi c'est un vraiment
un bel enseignement de cet exercice et
la mobilisation des gilet jaune se
poursuit 11e actes qui étaient au
programme samedi dans les yvelines une
marche citoyenne qui était organisée
entre poissy et saint-germain-en-laye nu
une manifestation pacifique sur fond
d'élections européennes avec une liste
menée par une gilet jaune sur le sujet
pardon de nicolas landry et au rayon
[Musique]
ambiance samedi après-midi dans les rues
de saint germain en laye pour l'acteur
11 du mouvement des gilet jaune près de
cent manifestants ont marché depuis
poissy une mobilisation pacifiste
encadrés par les forces de l'ordre
depuis plus de deux mois elle les
revendications n'ont pas changé
virez le président virer son
gouvernement changer de république
assène 6e un rique ça c'est très
important
et puis bah de meilleurs salaires
meilleure justice pour tout le monde
surtout et pour ses gilet jaune pas
besoin d'organiser de grand débat
national pour se faire entendre
débat il est plus précieux ici entre les
gens finalement le débat que son voisin
le débat en famille c'est ça qui est
important ce n'est pas le débat avec
macron qui fait sa pub pour les
européennes pour ces élections
européennes les gilet jaune seront
pourtant représenté avec une liste menée
par une grippe levavasseur liste qui ne
fait pas vraiment l'unanimité
je pense que ça a été fait beaucoup trop
tôt en fait il aurait dû attendre avant
de
de représenter les gilets jaunes si vous
prenez une liste aujourd'hui gilet jaune
elle va elle va dissoudre un le
mouvement et 2 ça va par rapport au
nombre de votes ça va donner de l' en
plus de pouvoir à maquereau ou autre ou
un autre parti politique
les manifestants doivent se consulter
cette semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
afin de savoir quelle suite donner à ce
mouvement
on ouvre à présent notre dossier du mois
consacré à la solidarité dans le
département des yvelines pour ce premier
volet on va avec aurélie rose rencontré
à les bénévoles des restos du coeur de
plaisir en plus de la distribution
alimentaire
le centre propose aussi des cours
d'informatique reportage il s'appelle
dominique xavier ou encore mireille et
ont tous un point commun plusieurs
heures par semaine ils sont au total une
cinquantaine de bénévoles ici au sein
des restos du coeur de plaisir on a deux
mois voilà à la distribution des
produits frais didier il est encore en
activité mais sur son temps libre il
viendrait d une semaine sur deux je vais
pv ya 15 ans se faire ça quand je serai
en retraite et après je vous suis ni
pour la presse à un peu loi autres
profils jean-paul en retraite
il vient les mardis et jeudis matins en
donner des cours d'informatique
c'était pour avoir déjà une occupation
occuper d aider des gens qui auraient
besoin
au début je n'étais pas informatique
je m'occuperai d'eux d'aller dans les
supermarchés récupérer la marchandise
ensuite j'ai des à la distribution est
depuis trois ans chez l'atelier
informatique et d
la principale motivation qui pousse tous
ces bénévoles à franchir la porte de ce
centre des restos du coeur
après une matinée d'essai ils sont
intégrés ou non à l'équipe s'il n'y a
pas de critères établis il faut
néanmoins posséder des qualités humaines
surtout est à l'écouté des autres parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est pas qu'un
problème alimentaire en général il ya
d'autres problèmes autres et là dans ces
cas là il faut il faut savoir être à
l'écouté
et puis pouvoir rediriger après ce qu'on
a des équipes de relais quand même eux
qui s'occupent de tout tout ce qu'il
peut y avoir d'autres problèmes comme le
logement ou
des problèmes financiers jeudi 9 heures
ok comme la dame qui vient que je viens
de voir là et bien presque toutes les
semaines pour différentes des lettres
administration des choses à numériser
210 familles en majorité plaisir oies
sont inscrits dans ce centre selon la
structure de leur foyer elles viennent
une ou deux fois par semaine pour la
distribution alimentaire
alors j'ai du jambon si ça peut vous
intéresser
des naines comme ça des ouais il ya de
tout dans le bénévole et il ya de tout
dans les accueillis aussi donc il ya des
gens il ya des gens qu'on connaît depuis
quinze ans qu'ils sont là qui il ya des
gens tirent pas alors je dirais là
le
mauvais côté de ces cons les gens pas
pour sais pas s'ils viennent c'est
positif au négatif
on espère que c'est positif mais des
fois on sait pas la vie et c'est ça qui
manque un peu
c'est à dire le la presse en fait
engagement investissements chaleur
humaine
voilà ce qui ressort après cette matinée
passée avec les bénévoles des restos du
coeur de plaisir des bénévoles qui
agissent ensemble pour faire vivre la
solidarité voulu il y à 34 ans par
coluche ou trouver un emploi grâce à un
match de football c'est une initiative
insolite lancé par l' agence d'insertion
départementale activity pour en parler
saulnier arrighi bonsoir vous êtes à la
directrice adjointe de l'agencé activité
alors cette action se nomme un match une
rencontre un emploi et va être
expérimenté à partir du mois de février
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines pourquoi lancer une telle
initiative
notre premier objectif c'était de
essayer de toucher les jeunes des jeunes
notamment présents en quartiers
politique de la ville puisqu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la moitié nos
bénéficiaires du rsa sont âgés de moins
de 35 ans donc ça ça c'est un fait
aujourd'hui on est dans une dynamique
aussi au sein du département le
département a lancé toute une politique
de rénovation autour des quartiers
politique de la ville donc c'est aussi
autant de on va dire de d'opportunités
qui se lancent sur ce sujet là et donc
ont souhaité accompagner son mouvement
il sait aussi sortir du cadre
traditionnel des conventions des forums
emploi c'est aussi de proposer autre
chose s'est proposée de choses aller
directement au contact des jeunes de
faire aussi un instant qu'il soit
convivial un instant où ils puissent
être eux-mêmes découvrir les entreprises
que ce soit aussi un petit peu
décloisonner moins stressant pour eux et
puis vraiment encore une fois l'objectif
c'est qu'ils puissent rencontrer les
gens se positionner et à la fin bien sûr
trouver un emploi parce qu'aujourd'hui
ces jeunes ils n'aiment pas forcément
sur sur ses forums emploi il ya un
malade du mal à les attirer pas
nécessairement en fait on gare un
phénomène qui est directrice mme on sait
que par exemple en mission locale la
moitié des jeunes n'ont pas d'adressé
email alors alors donc ça peut être
contre intuitif et on peut dire avec un
ca g facebook etc
mais non quand il faut faire les
démarches et ses terrasses et les jeux
ne sont pas toujours le mieux le métier
donc là c'est vraiment on essaie de
créer un espace où ils puissent
directement rencontrer des entreprises
et donc à aller vers l'emploi et
pourquoi le football c'est parce que
c'est l'un des sports les plus
populaires complètement c'est ce qui
nous a paru le plus évident le plus
simple aussi pour aller au contact
et puis enfin le sport on sait très bien
tout ce que ça peut aussi véhiculer
comme engagement voilà c'est cet aspect
aussi informel qui nous a beaucoup
séduit
cet engouement de la coupe du monde
aussi avec la victoire de la france qui
a fait soulever les foules en france
alors l'objectif on l'a compris c'est se
faire rencontrer des candidats et des
demandeurs à l'emploi et à des
recruteurs au cours d'un match de
football comment on trouve un match
comment on trouve pardon un job au cours
d'un match de football comment comment
c'est possible mais c'est très simple
avenant et en semaine et puis en allant
discuter avec les entreprises qui seront
présentes qui sont aussi là pour ça
l'objectif c'est pas à la fin de faire
un entretien on va dire de manière très
très habitué à elle avait l'objectif
c'est vraiment de venir sur le terrain
de discuter de les rencontrer dire ce
qu'on a envie ce dont on n'a pas envie
d'y poser ces questions et bien son cv
c'est juste de la discussion commune
éric un cv on peut venir avec un cv ou
je viens en fait c'est un peu comme avec
dana là on vient comme on est l'objectif
c'est vraiment d'aller à la rencontre
donc si on a un cv qu'il est prêt c'est
génial c'est encore mieux si on n'a pas
de cv et qu'on a envie c'est tout ce
qu'il faut et s'est rencontrés seront
organisés grâce aux à l'appui aussi des
clubs locaux il ya un partenariat qui
veulent la blogo convinrent à voir avec
les clubs locaux on va aussi se
rapprocher au fur et à mesure de toutes
les entreprises locales donc ça c'est
tout un maillage territorial qu'on est
en train de mettre en oeuvre et qui nous
semble aussi très important pour réussir
cette action mais du coup excusez moi du
terme en cas de tacle par derrière de
mauvais coup est-ce que ça ça annihile
toute les chances de trouver un emploi
consommateurs saignements pas
l'essentiel c'est justement ça c'est de
jouer c'est d'être soi même et puis non
au contraire on prend ton et comment va
se dérouler l'expérimentation j'ai eu
tout à l'heure elle débute en février
sur le territoire de 50 ans vivent
exactement la première date donc c'est
le 11 février
c'est à 18h30 à guyancourt donc j'ai un
numéro de téléphone ont signalé 18,2 on
a des adresses mails qui s'affiche en
bas d'écran on peut contacter pour plus
d'informations mais donner le numéro de
téléphone alors il faut contacter
mathilde valoir donc c'est au 06 74 82
53 18
donc si vous voulez venir vous inscrire
vous êtes les bienvenus et encore une
fois
avec ou sans cv juste avec la motivation
c'est tout ce qu'il faut et dernière
question les entreprises sont
intéressées par ce type secret très
intéressé c'est aussi à leur demande
qu'on a organisé ça voilà on a cherché à
rapprocher l'offre et la demande
on a les entreprises on a lu jeunes non
il faut juste en premier match en
février guyancourt c'est le premier
rendez-vous à retenir merci et ce n'est
réglé merci avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice adjointe de
l'agencé départementale d'insertion
activity il nous a rejoints au cours de
cet entretien bonsoir miquel et demi
d'euros vincent rigaud riz avec vous on
parle sport bien sûr comme chaque
semaine mickaël ce qu'il faut retenir
des rencontres et compétitions du week
end dans le département on commence par
un sport insolite le hisse porte
je sais que vous êtes un fan un grand
fan un grégory de 7 des civils pour la
deuxième année consécutive un tournoi de
ea sports était organisée à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles
des dizaines de joueurs professionnels
ou amateurs se sont affrontés sur le jeu
of stone ce jeu de cartes virtuelles
basées sur l'univers du célèbre jeu
world of warcraft est considéré
aujourd'hui comme un sport à part
entière on écoute l'un des joueurs à
1000 cas el louz alias maric au micro de
tv 60 vite j'ai pas vraiment la presse
sports mais il ya beaucoup de
similitudes c'est à dire qu'on
s'entraîne beaucoup on analyse nos
matches être capable d'être concentré
tout longue d'un match et même de
plusieurs matches quand on doit jouer
plusieurs sur une journée c'est pas
toujours quelque chose facile même bien
boire entre les matchs etc
ces deux réflexes que tout le monde m'a
pas et qui sont très importants qu'on
veut faire la différence au trou livres
au total au rendez-vous encore réuni
cette année plus de 500 passionnés une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine on l'a compris est un
sport qui devient de plus en plus
populaires y avait également du cyclisme
sur piste ce week-end oui grégory
troisième finale de la coupe d'hiver 2
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition regroupait cette année
huit clubs franciliens de la catégorie
minime aux élites
l'événement est en pleine expansion il
est passé de 90 à plus de 130
participants depuis sa création on
écoute l'un des organisateurs jean
michel richer ça fait partie des
objectifs de beaucoup de coureurs et de
beaucoup de pistard et cette coupe
d'hiver fait partie
d'une très bonne préparation et pour
certains ils vont attaquer les épreuves
sur route notamment les coureurs
d'endurance pour attaquer les épreuves
sur route dans un mois et donc c'est une
excellente préparation à la piste une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine des manches
supplémentaires pourraient être ajoutés
objectif pérenniser l'événement dans le
temps on termine par un résultat de
handball dans le championnat de
nationale 2 féminin rien n'arrête
montigny le bretonneux les filles de
denys choulet se sont imposés pour la
troisième fois consécutive en 2019 leurs
victimes du jour stella sport sa mort le
score est lui sans appel 24 à 18 pour
les inhumant ten un résultat qui permet
à montigny le bretonneux de s'emparer de
la septième place et de revenir à quatre
points du podium
merci michael rassurer nos
téléspectateurs lycée passé d'autres
choses dans le sport yves binois ce
week-end beaucoup d'autres choses
vraiment du football
il y aura également du basket y aura
plein de sport et l'ensemble de ses
résultats événements à retrouver bien
sûr dans votre émission le 7-8 sport
juste après ce journal c'est la fin de
cette édition le cetud journal est à
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]